[Music]
but George Clooney is nothing in obscene
politics compared to the man whose
picture I could have put up that I
thought you might sue me or put an FBI
hit out on me Donald Trump so I'm gonna
leave him obscenely unimaginative the
king of obscene politics in the to roots
right the Latin and the Greek and his
Access Hollywood bus ride sort of it was
a brilliant collision of the two that
famous bus ride that we many people
thought would undo him but didn't in
which he said tons of obscene grotesque
misogynist things that was the Latin
side of the root but in that he was
caught accidentally off stage wasn't he
he was miked by accident the this is
seemingly a private conversation
and so it had elements of the Greek
obscenity as well now this I just wanted
to read you a bit from the book at this
point just because there's a lot of
quotes in it and it's a bit complicated
but I just wanted you to think about how
Donald Trump is always using the abyss
eenz view not just with twit tweeting
all the time from his sort of bedroom at
11:00 p.m. but his whole campaign
strategy was to undermine normal
political structures by calling
attention to them in an obscene way so
as I write like a good attic comedian of
the Greek Theatre one of Donald Trump's
a murdering the election was to call
attention to the theatrical necessities
of the campaign unlike his 59 year old
bus ride himself he always knew where
the cameras were pointed during the
press conference to announce former
rival Ben Carson's endorsement of him
Trump voiced his frustration that during
his big Stadium rallies the cameras
never turn around to show the size of
his audiences even then it was gone
about audience eyes he also unveiled his
behind-the-scenes strategies the
ruthlessness of his machination x' after
Ben Carson edged ahead in a poll Trump
recalled to the reporters I said this
guy's unbelievable and so I started
going after Ben and it's politics and
Ben understands that my Trump impression
is impeccable Trump strategy all along
was to highlight the artificiality
and contingencies of the political stage
but it was during this press conference
that Ben Carson put the cat amongst the
postmodern pigeons there are two
different Donald Trump's Carson said
there's the one you see on the stage and
the one who there's the one who's very
cerebral who sits there and considers
things very carefully and that's the
Donald Trump that you're going to start
seeing more and more of right now it was
still waiting after a fumbling hug Trump
took over the podium to answer questions
in the journalists in attendance pursued
Carson's theory with great interest
they asked Trump to expand on this
proposed uality they use words such as
persona character and performance Trump
initially agreed with the verdict I
think there are two Donald Trump's
there's the public version and people
see that and it seems to have worked
over my lifetime but it's probably
different I think from the personal
Donald Trump now while it doesn't seem
unreasonable for someone to suggest that
they behave differently in public than
in private life
Trump is too keen to insist on the
inherent falsity of the politicians
public life for this distinction to be
useful useful to him speaking about
campaign financing he said the past
experience in early elections prepared
him for this one I know from the real
side he claimed not the politicians side
and so it wasn't long before he
distanced himself from Carson's - Trump
model which compromised his position as
unmediated and unmasked I don't think
there's two Donald Trump's he said
adding with a tortuous
existentialism worthy of Sartre I tried
to be Who I am
think of that for a second I tried to be
Who I am and now where does this leave
us somewhat a politician who brazenly
positions himself as an obscene figure
who will say politics is like this it's
corrupt Iowa you know this is how it all
works and I'm going to make it real and
yet profiting from the whole system and
there was a thinker called her hair bear
mark who's who said that obscenity of
the Latin sort of the of the disgusting
sort of crude swear word he kind of
obscenity was in one mode of resistance
that we had he said if someone is taking
public office in trying to
decorously say awful things then we can
shout insults at them call them pig or
whatever or things like that but what
happens when the person themselves who's
taking office no longer abides by the
codes of the normal decency and is
himself an obscene politician those
shouts of calling him present president
pig and mark uses words or saying oink
oink oink whenever he speaks when he
when the oink's are already sort of
filtered in naturally by the politician
themselves what sort of our next act of
resistance for more debates talks and
interviews subscribe today to the
institute of arts and ideas at iai TV
you